hi
i'm hannah from tasty and i'm here with
my family we are self-isolating um and
the kids are out of school which means
all of us are home
all day long pretty much and
stir crazy is an understatement but one
really great way to keep kids occupied
and entertained and keep them focused is
to cook together so we'd like to show
you some of our easiest favorite recipes
that we like to cook together this is
jackson how old are you hey this is
wyatt how old are you hi
and this is henry and how old is he
three months three months and so it's
all of us together we're gonna do this
and today we're gonna show you our very
favorite no-bake pudding bars
first and foremost clean hands did we
all wash our hands
yes
awesome so let's
start with the crust now i'm going to be
offering a lot of substitutions for all
of this because let's be real the
grocery stores are bananas right now um
you can't even get bananas right now at
our grocery store so
luckily these recipes are very flexible
even the amounts are very flexible so
you can kind of just wing it with
whatever you have the first thing we're
going to make is the crust we're using
shortbread cookies i bought these on
sale
not really knowing what i was going to
do with them allow that and here we are
so we're going to place some shortbread
cookies in
big plastic bags do you guys want to do
this you put this one in this bag
and why you will put this one in the
other bag let's see how much we get
i love cookies
you can use graham crackers for this you
could use chocolate cream sandwich
cookies you could use pretty much any
kind of cookie you love
um this is a very very flexible recipe
do you get them all we're gonna peel
these up
boom so we only have one rolling pin so
wyatt
you are going to use your rolling pin
and jackson you're going to use your
pure hulk strength
to smash these cookies you want them in
fine little bits ready begin
[Music]
it looks like those all need a little
bit more crumble you guys oh yeah these
crumble up really nicely let's do a
little white one
how do those look
good
it feels like a squishy so this is very
finely crushed
and then this guy
out like a light so we want about three
cups of crushed cookies one
okay that's two now one more you don't
want to lose any crumbs
oh yeah
give it a whiff
[Music]
you're thirsty
okay
take plenty of water braids
[Music]
so why you're gonna add
the butter to the cookie crumbs right
looks good it's the butter volcano and
then you stir that guy up
jackson you want to do it yeah
very gently though remember gentle
gentle
gentle
this is a great consistency i think
we're ready to press this into
the pan i'm going to eat it
look i've already lined this
8x8 baking dish this is lined with some
parchment
we're gonna get all of this in oh yeah
get all those cookies
[Music]
okay so we're gonna take our cup
and press
this crust down can you guys do a little
go over hold on okay guys across gentle
gentle
gentle
this is gonna chill
we'll refrigerate this while we make our
filling this is a really easy pudding
filling so we have one
i think it's a 3.4 ounce one packet of
pudding
[Music]
and can we whisk that up what do we say
when we do it
okay
it's bubbles
i mean it's
yeah it's bubbles let's see the
consistency of this
it's thicker we only used about half as
much milk you're supposed to add
okay who's doing whipped cream
[Music]
wow
quick break to taste
pudding how's that
delicious
so instead of whipped cream you can use
whipped topping from the freezer how's
that taste
good why how do you feel amazing
[Music]
okay so we're going to learn how to fold
in so we want to
pull it up from the bottom
and fold it back on top and push so you
want to try
yeah
you're doing a great job folding
excellent wyatt would you like to try
yes okay this is beautiful
great stirring
it's almost ready to pour over our crust
here let me do a couple just to get the
bottom oh my gosh this looks delicious i
would just eat this out of a bowl i
would eat it out of a bag let's pour it
onto the crust okay here we go
i'm gonna pour this in for you guys and
then you're gonna spread it out can you
spread it out wyatt
gentle oh what do we say
gentle
while the bars are in the fridge we're
going to make a quick chocolate ganache
this is totally optional you don't have
to make this they're good to eat as they
are um with big chilled but we
just have chocolate chips and we have
cream so we're going to do it we have
sprinkles and we have sprinkles why not
let's get festive
so this is hot cream this is gonna go
over some chocolate chips this hot cream
is gonna melt the chocolate chips
and all we did was microwave it for
about 45 seconds
look how glossy this is guys yes
glossier
you want to finish it off what do you
mean we're stirring
gentle
oh yeah
oh yeah
chocolate the master snack
the master snack you mean the master
dessert
no the master snack all right wyatt
sprinkle time yeah like oh that's salt
guys
salt bae
something sweet
dumplings
sprinkles okay so our pudding bars are
in the freezer that's where you can put
them if you want them to set up a little
quicker we want to eat them after dinner
so we're gonna
put them in the freezer you can also set
them in the refrigerator um i think we
need
[Music]
who did that
i'm watching these clips as i'm
uploading them um somebody
somebody farted
the good thing about these desserts is
while they're setting in the freezer
that means in order to have a piece we
gotta have good behavior while they're
freezing right
good behavior
calm
don't jump off the bunk beds
don't run into a closed door because
we're running in the house
right yeah don't kick your brother
yeah don't kick your brother
right
and so there's really good behavior
while the bars are freezing
we can have one after dinner
[Music]
oh my goodness um
doesn't this look amazing
that looks amazing yummy
you want to get to the table yeah this
is mine
goodbye give it a try
is it good
did we do a good job
how does it look wyatt
you guys did amazing you proud of
yourself yeah it was easy huh bye say
bye
bye oh yes
[Music]
you